hello
is this thing on yes
all right how's everybody yeah happy
2018 everybody excited to be another
trip around the Sun everybody good yeah
awesome I'm gonna switch hands actually
I couldn't hold the microphone with my
right hand it felt weird so I just watch
anyway welcome to Rockville University
to our newly rebranded Rock edu presents
science cafe for high school students so
previously known as lol but we almost
got sued so we had to change the name I
don't know it's pretty exciting to
receive this like giant cease and desist
letter it was my first and I hopefully
it was my last but now we're rocky do
you presents so how many repeat
customers do we have for rocky do you
presents amazing how many of you are new
to Rockefeller well thank you for coming
welcome what school are you guys from
what school reppin land awesome uh who
else is new only Brooke of it where are
you from nevermind okay awesome cool so
um yeah are you new what's it help for
oh you're not new
[Laughter]
goldstein high school for the sciences
where's that in Manhattan it's what it's
Coney Island yeah Oh Manhattan Beach oh
there's a book by Jennifer Egan out
Manhattan Beach did you guys read it no
not yet I'm not sure if if I'm gonna
make an assumption it doesn't fit your
demographic but maybe it will yeah cool
so welcome again today we are going to
be talking about a very awesome topic
related to evolution but before we do I
just want to talk about rocky to you so
many of you may know me I'm Jeanne
Garbarino I'm the director of rocky do
you science outreach here at Rockefeller
and we are really pleased to have the K
through 12 community walking through our
gates every single day through lab
experiences through research programs
like lab jumpstart so I know a lot of
you have applied to lab jumpstart we
have also have the summer science
research program or s SRP during the
summer so if you are interested in doing
more beyond attending a lecture series
like this and you want to get your hands
dirty in science research in any way
please learn about our programs on our
website or come talk to me I'll be happy
to talk to you about what we have for
you to get engaged with science in a
very deep way also if you would like to
do any kind of social media inge if
that's a verb I'm not sure we use the
hashtag Rock edu so you can find us on
Instagram you can find us on Twitter
does anybody use Twitter no right how
about yeah we oh yeah we have one person
feel free to live tweet how about
Facebook is anybody on Facebook because
you can like our page on Facebook but
you can feel free to also snap all right
if you want to snap any of this we keep
on asking snapchat to let us have a geo
filter and they keep on declining our
request well one day we're gonna have a
pretty sweet geo filter for you guys to
use for snapping um and yeah I guess
well let's get this party started right
so we are excited to bring to you two
amazing scientists Diane Kelly and patty
Brennan so Diane is a functional
morphologist which is kind of like
someone who does mechanical engineering
in Reverse for animals and she does this
at UMass Amherst patty is an
evolutionary biologist who works at
Mount Holyoke College in the biology
department and both have studied genital
anatomy and function in a wide variety
of vertebrates and in this talk they
will share what they've learned about
how evolution has driven the amazing
diversification of form and function in
copulatory organs so this is going to be
a great talk and it is certainly central
to biology so I'm very excited that we
get to bring this to you today so thank
you both for coming and I'm gonna kick
it off in and hand it over to you hello
everybody
can everybody hear me okay this is not
enough all right excellent so we could
team dip front lights a little bit no be
fine
thank you said the mood you know we're
gonna be talking about some
that's right
[Laughter]
so I'm gonna get started by talking
about something that's probably a little
bit more familiar to all of you which
has to do with mating in nature so a lot
of biologists and a lot of scientists
for a long time have been studying what
we call the struggle for mating which
was the idea that Darwin had you know
over a hundred and fifty years ago that
it has to do with what animals will do
to actually reproduce right and
oftentimes that results in the evolution
of traits that can be a little bit
counterintuitive so remember that Darwin
you know was all about
traits that would increase survival but
then you notice that there were some
traits that didn't really seem to
increase survival in fact they look like
they would really not help at all and so
if you look here in this sage-grouse
here is a male and here's the female and
you can see he's not like camouflage or
hidden in any way he's got all these
crazy traits that make him very
conspicuous and so why would a male have
such weird traits well the answer is
because he wants to have sex with
someone and in order to do that he's
really in that struggle for meaning he
is gonna make himself beautiful or he's
gonna make himself seem really you know
competitive and and have traits that are
gonna help him to out-compete other
mouths and so either he's gonna have
traits that allow him to seduce the
female so she looks at him and she
thinks he's very sexy and so she's gonna
mate with him but it also oftentimes
results in traits that promote males
winning a fight for example and I have
some examples here so for example
beetles they have this nasty horns or
their antlers in deer that allowed the
males to win fights and Darwin assumed
that this was pretty much the end of
this story right because remember Darwin
lived in the Victorian era where
essentially you know you had sex for the
purpose of having babies and women had
sex with only one person and that was it
so whoever you made it with that was it
that was the one who was going to sire
the babies and it turns out that since
then we've actually learned that
struggle is really not for mating the
struggle is actually for fertilization
because females it turns out are not
monogamous in nature right and I'm not
talking about human females although
that can apply for human females as well
but I'm talking about females in nature
in general females are not monogamous
they tend to mate with lots of different
males and then they choose among those
males sperm that they would prefer to
use to sire their babies so the struggle
is really for fertilization and this is
something that we have learned a lot
more recent maybe in the past four
decades or so and so during this
struggle there are different events
right that are not necessarily like the
traits are just show you seducing a
female or out competing arrival but
traits that can happen during copulation
itself so for example things they have
to do with the stimulating the female so
the female will be more likely to use
the sperm from those males or to deposit
sperm farther inside of the female so
they'll sperm will have a higher chance
to actually fertilizing the eggs so they
can happen both during copulation or
after copulation so after the sperm are
already inside the female sperm for
example have different swimming speeds
and speed and sperm that swim faster are
the ones that are more likely to
fertilize the eggs and then the eggs
themselves can actually often reject
sperm that they do not want to use to
fertilize their eggs and it's a really
fascinating area of evolutionary biology
understanding these processes and so we
know actually a fair amount about what
happens here in this after copulation
events but we know almost nothing about
what happens during copulation itself
okay so this is this is really odd if
you think about it we know less about
copulation than about any other behavior
in nature and this is all because if you
are interested in evolution actually
copulation is really where is that right
because your evolutionary success is
going to depend on whether you are able
to pass on your genes to the next
generation and you can only do that if
you're successful during population more
successful than other males or more
successful than other females in getting
better genes for your offspring
so a population is essentially critical
to evolutionary success so we know and
we have known for again for a few
decades that genitalia are probably one
of the most diverse organs that we find
in the animal kingdom so this is
actually these are illustrations from a
book called sexual selection and animal
genitalia that was published about 40
years ago and right here these are a
bunch of hemi pins from snakes and you
can see that they look a little bit like
medieval torture devices right they have
like all these nasty spines and you're
like what that's a penis that looks
really weird and and it does look really
weird but this is snakes these ones over
here on the right are mammals right so
if you look at mammals mammals also are
incredibly diverse in the shape of their
genitalia many species also have spines
weird hooks all sorts of things going on
in there you have a question yeah so
this is the cloaca right here that I'll
show you I'm gonna show you a picture so
you're gonna see exactly where but it's
like tucked inside their tail and it
only comes out when they're gonna mate
so you never see so the question is why
would you tell you be so diverse if you
think about it the job of alpha male in
trauma tent organ is really simple is
essentially to put sperm as close as
possible to the female eggs that's it
that's what internal fertilization is
all about and you could do that with a
simple tube but of course this genitalia
are not as simple to write they're
really complicated so why do we need to
go to such lengths in order to perform
where it would seem to be a fairly
straightforward biological function so
there are several potential explanations
the oldest one is up here species
isolation is this lock and key idea this
was a hypothesis that was proposed maybe
in the 1800s and it was proposed for
insects because it turns out that
insects have such diverse genitalia that
you can oftentimes sex species that
otherwise completely identical on the
outside by looking at differences in
their genitalia and that's how you tell
species apart so what people figure what
scientists figure well
that essentially the male genitalia are
like keys that are fitting into
specialized locks which are the female
genitalia to prevent them from mating
with the wrong species
so the reserves to reinforce species
formation now since then the seems like
a reasonable idea and there are a few
species of specially insects where this
seems to be the case but by and large
it's shown not to be a general pattern
to explain the diversity of genitalia
instead what seems to be happening are
more hypotheses related to sexual
selection so again success during mating
and fertilization okay and so that are
again same processes as we see just to
gain a mating so it's competition among
males and this essentially takes the
form of males they have longer penises
than their competitors can deposit their
sperm farther inside of the female
therefore they're gonna win the
fertilization it can also be in the form
of female choice males they have penile
features that allow them to better
stimulate the females are gonna be more
successful because the females will be
more likely to use sperm from those
males and I see some of you are going
like whoa yes yes it's true and then
there is also sexual conflict and sexual
conflict is a really cool mechanism is
actually probably the one that I'm gonna
be talking about the most today because
it's the one that I have sent her my
research on and what this is about is
essentially that we know and we
understand that the evolutionary
interest of males and females are not
the same so even though both males and
females want to raise babies together
most of the time how much work each one
of those each one of the sexes is going
to put into successfully reproducing
it's different so everybody wants to get
away with cheating a little bit in this
game and that can result oftentimes in
in really counter out counterintuitive
adaptations that often play out in the
genitalia and I'm gonna show you some
examples of these so for a long time I
have been studying ducks and so this is
a photo actually from the cover of
nature this is an Argentine Lake duck
and he
penis is about 43 centimeters long much
longer than the male himself
I know it's just evolution is cool I
tell you people and so so this whole
thing this whole penis is kept inside
out in the body of the male okay and
this is by the way like the champion
among the vertebrates and Diana and I
are going to be talking about vertebrate
genitalia today because if you look at
insects forget about it you know it's
like completely crazy in there but there
was a paper that came out a few years
ago where they found an interesting
pattern they found that the size of this
enormous penis in ducks was actually
related to just how promiscuous they
were so species that are more
promiscuous meaning species where the
females are mating with more males
tended to have much longer penises and
so that would suggest that some kind of
mechanism maybe of male-male competition
that was driving the size of these
penises but in my research I was
actually really in a way almost
concerned about where this penis
actually goes because if the penis is
this big like it's the female like empty
does she have like no body organs
anywhere you know like you have to
wonder and it turns out that intercept
that nobody had actually asked that
question even though you know dogs are
everywhere in the world we eat dogs that
are like farms where dogs are you know
dead everywhere nobody had actually
wondered well if the if a dog penis can
look like that what does it talk vagina
actually look like so this is this this
is an illustration really of how
important it is to have diversity in
science because I think it was a
combination of the fact that I'm a woman
and of course you know I saw this and I
was like right where does it go you know
I wouldn't know so the fact that I was a
woman but also the fact that I'm latina
and you know there are people from other
cultures
that are a lot more reserved around
sexual issues who will probably
Decapitator for saying the word vagina
out loud but I am NOT from one of those
cultures and so we tend to have a little
bit a little bit more open when it comes
to sexual discussions and so I think
that that was also something that helped
me come up with this this idea and so I
went out there and I looked at female
ducks and I was very surprised because
what I found so here I'm showing you
here's a male penis and in this case
it's not as long as the other one this
is a Peking duck so this is the kind of
duck that you would see running around
in a farm and so they have the penises
corkscrew shape and what I found this is
the female so the females have a cloaca
so this is the event or Chloe Kyle
opening in birds where the both the poop
and the sperm come out from and so the
the females they have these vaginas that
are incredibly convoluted right and what
is really interesting about it is that
when you look at the male penis how it
spirals the male spiral in a
counterclockwise direction whereas the
females who spiral on a clockwise
direction and they have a series of
pouches at the entrance of the vagina
that are essentially blind pockets so it
looks literally like this is an anti
screw device because he's going in the
opposite direction then the pattern in
the male so why would there be such a
such a need for having this weird
genitalia well the reason is actually
because in Ducks promiscuity takes a
really dark turn ducks by an arch form
pair bonds where the males and the
females stick around together but it
turns out that oftentimes ducks that are
not paired males that don't get a mate
that will actually fly around to the
breeding grounds in the spring and they
will find females who are in breeding
condition and force them to copulate and
that's shown in this little illustration
here so there is a female in the middle
and she's surrounded by a bunch of males
that are essentially trying to force her
to copulate so what we're looking at
here is an example of sexual conflict
what I described as the difference in
evolutionary interest between the
and the females that has led to the
evolution of this really convoluted
genitalia now the really cool thing
about it is that you can actually go and
look at a bunch of different species of
ducks
so not all Ducks have this force
populations many ducks are really really
nice really you know they don't go
around pursuing females or anything like
that so Ducks that are pretty monogamous
purely monogamous they have very short
penises like this Harlequin duck and
these African geese and you can see that
the female vaginas are just straight
tubes okay so there are simple tubes no
convoluted structures whatsoever but
here and here here we have a long tailed
duck and a mallard duck and both of
those have lots of force populations
going on and you can see that in those
species the male penis is long and the
female vaginas are really convoluted so
that's a clear example of coevolution so
essentially the penis allows the male
ducks to force females to copulate and
the females have evolved a counter
strategy that prevents those males from
being successful and this is an
illustration of how this actually works
we have done a series of experiments
where we have shown that this is really
the mechanism of exclusion of the penis
essentially where the penis just gets
turned around in this labyrinth in
female structure and then the females
regain control over which males are
actually going to sire their babies and
they always give more paternity back to
their own partner than these unwanted
males that are literally falling out of
the sky to try to gain fertilizations
and so it's a really cool example of how
this sexual conflict can drive these
evolutionary patterns of diversity in
genitalia and so of course you're
probably wondering well but the females
have this weird complicated vaginas how
do they have sex with the duck that they
like right oh they're how do they have
sex with the with the duck that they
like and the answer is that when females
are gonna have sex with their own mate
the male actually does have pre
copulatory dance where he you know goes
around with his feathers
you know those all sorts of fancy
displays that may essentially put her in
the mood she lays brown in the water
with her tail up and then she starts
contracting her cloaca and that helps to
relax her bagina so that then she can
allow her partner her her wanted partner
to actually go through the lumen of her
vagina the opening of her vagina so
anyway it's a really cool system to
actually look at these questions of
sexual conflict but I was really curious
to see well are these ducks just weird
because the story I just told you it's
like a weird story right it's like oh my
gosh it's like force copulations and
weird penises going one way and we're
vaginas going the other way so is this
just a weird strange thing that happens
in ducks just because there are strange
and it turns out it is not yep Oh in
there in the Ducks yeah so that's an
excellent question in fact they do not
Ducks hybridize like crazy and they
hybridize in both directions so males
with short penises and females
convoluted vaginas and males with long
penises and females with simple vaginas
so they hybridize across general if they
go any which way yeah they don't do all
kinds of crazy stuff yeah well so here's
so what happens with dogs typically a
question was what if another male were
to do the dance would she be more
interested so what happens with ducks is
that they actually pair on their pair
bonds during the winter in this
wintering ponds and during that time
there's always more male ducks than
female ducks and the reason has to do
with the fact that females do all the
incubation alone so they take to die
more because they get eaten at the nest
or they're in really poor body condition
by the time migration times come and
then when they migrate they just die
more right and so there's always more
males
so the female is really choosing the
best marriage that she likes among all
the guys that are around right it's like
going to a dance and you know you go out
there and the sex ratio is like 80 guys
per 30 girls you would have him like
which male you would like so it's the
same situation so by the time she
actually makes a choice it's a guy that
she's really convincing the best quality
male and in fact these guys that are
doing this force populations are
essentially be able to canary losers of
the game so it's unlikely that they
would be accepted by the female because
her maid is likely to be a higher
quality already they choose males based
on their dancing abilities so the males
have male dogs have very stereotypical
Google a couple of videos and you'll see
they do all sorts of pure wedding and
great stuff and also the base so ducks
are also the most beautiful birds they
have really complicated image they have
a structural color in their feathers and
they also have pigmentation in their
bills and their legs and both of those
are signals of good health and great
questions you guys alright
and so but it turns out so what I'm
gonna say next is that Ducks are
actually not that weird
even though they're weird so in this
picture here the tail is down here right
so we're holding the tail and kind of
pushing up and snakes have actually two
penises they're called heavy pins and
they are full of spines typically closer
to the base and in the case of of the
snakes they actually use only one hand
pin at a time so it's not like they're
using both they're using one and then
the other one and if you look across
different species of snakes you you see
that there's a lot of diversity so
here's for example a couple of his
species of rattlesnakes you can see that
theme of having a bunch of spines
towards the base but you can see that
some of them are longer some of them are
thicker
here's a pretty garter snake so they can
have you know a little more hammer like
shapes etc and then what I'm showing you
here on the right are models that we
make of the female vagina but of the
inside of the female body right so I'm
interested in seeing how the male and
the female genitalia actually fit
together is there something happening
during population that is changing the
likelihood that one of these males is
gonna be more successful and so what we
do is we literally inject dental
silicone inside of the female Chloe we
let it cure and then we pull it out like
a little plastic lollipop and then we
make three-dimensional models of that
and then we do shape analysis to try to
see how these different structures are
evolving and you can see here I just put
two different examples of two species of
female snakes the one in the top is a
black rat snake and the one in the
bottom is a green vine snake just to
illustrate that the females are just as
variable as the males and so a while
back this idea that females could
actually be really variable was rejected
because I guess people hadn't really
looked all that carefully at the females
so nobody has been really examining so
one of the things that I do is then I
actually in my lab wing we do this
little bit of Frankenstein Frankenstein
science where we take the specimens that
we remove from the males and the females
and then we play the males in secret
inside of the female and this is not
exactly like copulation I know because
everybody's dead but it is as close as
we're gonna get right it's like what I'm
showing you here this is a model that we
made showing the male that's shown in
green here inside of the female vagina
which is shown in this kind of
transparent tissue and one of the
interesting things is that if we don't
know how the male and the female fit
together it's really hard to understand
destructors so these smells actually are
got species that I show you when I eat
play the male alone their Hemi penis
looked kind of like a little hammer but
when I even played them inside of the
female they actually adult the shape of
the female which makes a lot of sense so
we need to really study the male sense
out of the female and this is one of the
species that we've been looking at try
to understand a little bit better the
evolution of that particular feature of
those spines and so we did some work in
Manitoba beautiful place where red-sided
garter snake thousands and thousands of
snakes on the floor you have to be like
excuse me excuse me
and you know move the snakes out and
they're preoccupied only with having sex
so we garter snakes so for the met one
of you is to his advantage to populate
longer because he can make a bigger club
from the female point of view though
she's like no there are lots of other
males here so there's like there between
the male and the female so we did some
experiments where essentially we allow
the males to mate and then we actually
cut their spine so we cut their camping
spots literally using a tiny little pair
of scissors so we're just going there we
caught the spines and then we let them
may do better and when I did that see
these are the male swords
that is what we see so that's yet again
another example of sexual conflict so
there's one more example here and this
is evidence of sexual conduct
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Applause]
there's one even more so we did the same
thing where we played the male penis in
the vagina
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
all right so
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
one layer is
[Laughter]
[Music]
let's have a very different
we see in each group we see the same
pattern of popula torii style and the
function and functional aspects the
tissue is repeated over and over
three millions of years of evolution in
each group there is diversification but
it's like there are it's like there are
there are what is driving this
particular this particular point in
point in time because failure is an
option penises experience compressive
forces like various torsional forces
which means they can break what is
showing you the hematoma is not inside
the erectile tissue that is not good in
their glands those can break and vaginal
tissues can also experienced limitations
to what evolution can do for these
structures and structural arrangements
of general tissues and that might that
kind of natural selection that acts
against where failure produce a failure
to populate injury produces failure to
failure to reproduce may serve as a
counterweight to sexual selection and
the massive diversity the craziness the
sexual selection can produce and so
that's
[Applause]
we are going to come around with
microphones so that everybody can hear
your question and as always we do have
swag for the question asking and I just
want to say this was the best rock video
presents me ever heaven so thank you
alright so yeah okay so whoever needs to
get out of here go ahead and get out of
here but if you're staying do so quietly
so you're not interrupting other people
I'm gonna hand one of these microphones
over to Nika okay so raise your hand and
I'll start over here um do animals with
lower birth rates tend to have more
specialized genitalia
I do animal just low birth rates tend to
have more specialized in I tell you
that's an excellent question it really
is but I don't think that I don't think
it it no I don't think there's any sort
of direct correlation
is your motivation for studying about
this topic because it's awesome we're
sick old ladies alright I'll take one
over here no I'll answer that a little
bit more I was doing my PhD in Costa
Rica I was studying these birds that are
called Tina moves that nobody really
knows anything about and I was too
studying their mating system and I was
doing my PhD at Cornell University which
is like the best place to study birds in
the world right because everybody there
knows a lot about birds and one time I
was watching these birds and I saw them
mating and when the male pulled out from
the female I saw this thing hanging off
his cloaca and I was incredibly
surprised to learn that he was a penis
because that first one I saw it I
thought he had parasites like I had
never I had never heard the word bird
and penis in the same sentence so I
didn't even know the birds could have
penises and I was like they're so weird
so when I came back from Costa Rica I
started doing some reading and then I
found out that in fact nobody was
talking about bird penises for at least
a hundred years and I was like okay
looks like I have a project so there's a
Mayan and on my end I again when I was
doing my dissertation I was looking when
I was looking for a project to work on
for my doctoral studies I happen to be
working in a wonderful lab at Duke
University with so I had this fantastic
advisor who would literally let his
students do anything they wanted as long
as you could prove that it was beautiful
the if you could prove that it was it
was it had to be a scientist ient if
eclis beautiful and visually arresting I
happen to be really interested in the
problem of convergence is how you get
similar in in an illusionary context how
you get similar structures evolving
independently multiple times and
internal fertilisation is one of those
things that it has evolved when you look
across animals and his evolve many many
times independently and in a lot of time
you don't actually have to have a penis
in order to have internal fertilization
but often when you have once an animal
taxa it bulbs internal fertilization
some of them will evolve penises as well
so I got really interested in the
problem it's like how does this thing
work and I started doing the reading and
found out that no one knows how this
thing really works there was a lot of
work on how on vascular stuff you know
how blood goes in because guys get
really upset when that doesn't work
there's all a ton of work on there's a
ton of work on innovation and but it was
all very much in a medical sense rather
than how you know how does it work in
general and there was nothing on how the
how the soft tissues produce this
amazing change in flow from being
something really flexible to being
something really stiff which is you know
a really interesting mechanical problem
as well and as I said my adviser would
let us do whatever we wanted so he I was
able to show him a beautiful photo and
he said beautiful photo with the
collagen fibers and he said go ahead you
have a project and I've been doing it
for like 25 years now um so what are
your future research might be what are
you guys thinking about well so one of
the biggest things I'm doing right now
is I'm doing moving to three-dimensional
studies of all the different groups of
vertebrates penises and vaginas and so I
have a bunch of students in my lab who
essentially spent all the time doing
photogrammetry and we are working out on
the analysis technique for analyzing
these 3d models and figuring out how to
compare different species so we can get
at this question of how shape actually
evolves in different groups from a
common ancestor right so kind of like an
evolutionary understanding of that and
then the other big thing that we're
interested in is the clitoris clitoris
apologies so we're just starting looking
at the morphology of dolphins but I also
have a lot of tissues from birds and
reptiles that also have clitoris just
like mammals do and just kind of trying
to get out the question of sort of what
is pleasure sexual pleasure like for
other vertebrates that are not
necessarily humans or rats which are the
ones for which we know the most whereas
on my end
I'm I'm a motional morphologist and
physiologist I'm interested I'm very
interested in how does it work
so I'm working on a project one of my
projects is about crocodilians so I am
trying to that crocodilians have very
very unusual penises where there's there
permanently stiff because they have
stuff so much collagen into that bath
what was that vascular space that they
can no longer inflate themselves I mean
they just stay like a little stiff rod
inside their cloaca all the time so but
in order to get in order to be in order
to mate they have to push it out and
then it has to be if there are these two
to these sets of tendons that haul it
back in so one of my projects right now
is doing mechanical tensile tests of
those tendons to try to build try to
build up a picture of how their what
their mechanical properties actually are
one of the reasons that's interesting is
that there's really - this particular
system really has two sets of tendons
two of which act like big stretchy
rubber bands and just you know pull the
penis in really fast the other is more
like a point of contact sort of a
fulcrum - just that it rotates around
that holds it in place inside the cloaca
they're made of exactly the same
material there's no chemical difference
between them but they are they have
vastly different mechanical properties
and one that the I'm working with some
engineers because we're really they're
really interested in ways of taking one
material and turning it into your
turning it into a structure different
structures that have different
mechanical properties but by only using
one material and changing the way that
that's that material is arranged
all right so let's see how about over
here what what difficulties did you face
while conducting your research well I
stopped at the police one you were just
arrested one I was the policeman didn't
stop by this I was I was doing a
dissection on the side of the road and
the policeman like did want to know what
I was doing I was able to convince him
that I was not a lunatic or at least I
was not a dangerous lunatic yeah I think
I had a penis explode in my lab it was
all over my hair was everywhere I just
want to know why were you um dissecting
something on the side of the bail order
I wanted it really fresh it was already
dead it was road-killed
so but I wanted the specimen and I
wanted it really you know I wanted to
get her into the into the preservation
Floyd really fast rather than putting in
their bucket driving all you know
driving the 15 miles back to the lab and
then doing the dissection I wanted to
get what I needed right then I know you
know it's BIOS you told the story about
I did tell there's a podcast all about
it on the story Collider
I recommend listen I have one more
question
um do you see any organisms that have
sex has a more recreational activity
yeah for sure so there are two main
groups that we know have sex not
necessarily just for reproduction and
they are dolphins and bonobos so both of
them have sex for pretty much every
social circumstance and they have sex
males with males and females with
females and all sorts of things well it
gets it gets a lot kinkier than that
because it's like adults with juveniles
and you know yeah yeah yeah yeah it gets
really complicated really fast yeah but
yeah those are the two main examples so
um the two are the two types of animal
shoulder dots and dolphins since
dolphins are underwater and dogs are
like like surface are there any like
differences between them - since they're
in different types of locations sorry
the environment so being like on top of
the water versus under the water
dolphins are in the water how they
differ from the Ducks which so of course
dolphins have a big challenge it's a
two-fold challenge really one is that
they are in a three-dimensional
environment so mating in a
three-dimensional environment is a lot
harder right because getting it right
well okay not only that they're stuck
with the mammalian they're stuck with
the mammalian system where exact yunus
becomes erect and then they have to
navigate into the female so they
probably have a lot of drag acting on
the penis as a male is swimming really
fast trying to get on the female and
stuff like that so there's definitely
that is a big difference and then the
other one is also that because they are
in the water the there is the risk that
sea water is gonna enter inside of the
female and saltwater is lethal to
mammalian sperm so that would be a big
problem as well okay you've been waiting
how much and what kinds research has
been done to find the common ancestor
between mammal and non mammal gen
Italian has there been any progress well
the problem is that that ancestors long
gone say is that we have do you think
right so we have to use so what we do is
probably was comparative we use
comparative biology comparative biology
looks at you we accept that the we
accept the fact that the most recent
common ancestor the hypothetical common
ancestor whatever it was that's why it's
hypothetical we we're never we are
probably never going to see that
hypothetical common ancestor or find a
fossil of it but if we look at all of
the living organisms and try to figure
out what animals what these animals have
in common and find where and look look
at look at those animals on a good
family tree we can trace where change
has happened in that tree and credit
reconstruct a reconstruct a story and I
things changed over time and and the
other problem of course is that even if
there was you know some kind of
intermediate fossil form that you could
find soft tissues do not fertilize well
and so finding evidence of penis traits
or vagina traits would be pretty much
impossible
so my question is that so the class of
the animal and the reproduction so can
let's say a higher class male have wood
what a high class male have bigger or
smaller penis and when it just when it
comes to class does it what do you mean
by higher class so you mean like a high
class female who has a higher position I
mean the quality oh yeah like a high
quality male and I think it differs for
it's different for different species dry
dry dry it exactly yeah so there is a
there is a general principle when it
comes to reproduction that essentially
makes males a lot more likely to have
sex in more circumstances than females
and that's because theoretically
although this is kind of like an
oversimplification sperm are cheaper
than eggs and females tend to be the
ones that get stuck with all the
parental care and so it makes males more
likely to mate with more females so they
will be more likely to mate with females
regardless of the female quality than
females so from the female point of view
a female would always want to prefer a
higher quality mate than a lower quality
mate here yeah what limitations do you
see in like I guess future research in
both of your respective topics or lack
of there so with our current government
let's just say that there's not a lot of
support for its sex related research so
of course we're in the States which
despite all the progress we've made in
so many areas is still a very prudish
place and people are still like and so I
think that that's really the biggest
challenge is to get funding for this
kind of research in the current
political climate
well I think I say another challenge is
that there's just so much there's so
much that's not known I mean we can't do
it alone
we need help we need more people
interested in doing us over the course
of your studies have you encountered any
species that have prepared
countermeasures for sexual diseases
sorry for sexual diseases so I just
started a project where we are looking
at the immune regulation of the vagina
in female rats
so rats and mice males have lots of
spines in their penises and essentially
I want to test the hypothesis and I'm
collaborating with an immunologist the
females in species where the male's have
this penile spines that they have a
pre-existing immune response already in
place because they know that their
vaginal tissues are going to be torn and
you know scratched and all that during
mating and so that in those species
those females will be protected against
for example sexually transmitted
diseases but also trauma etc and they
would also have a faster healing
response in the face of those challenges
and so stay tuned yeah so there is all
in the crocodilian project that I'm
working on we've also one of my
collaborators on that came into it by
front by looking at the what's called
the sulcus so crocodiles don't
crocodilians don't have a closed urethra
the way that mammals do they it's an
open slit and because the you instant
because they're callous sits inside the
sits inside the cloaca and the cloaca is
this is a they only let's put it this
way they only have one hole there's only
one opening which means pee comes out of
it and poop comes out of it and sperm
and the and the penis with the sperm
comes out of it so everything goes in
there that cloaca is Latin for sewer so
you know it's a descriptive word
everything everything goes into the
sewer but one of the things he found and
was that some of the tissue inside this
this groove has a lot of immune immuno
immune system properties it produces
mucus that has a lot of white you know
produced that dumps and they dump a lot
of white blood cells in there and his
hypothesis is that that's because
there's all this other you know literal
crap that is all over the is all over
the phallus and that the sperm need to
kind of be protected against alright so
let's go with one more question so my
question is you talked about a lot about
animals that fertilize like inside but
what about animals that fertilize
externally like um fish and stuff like
that oh it's a whole other it's a whole
other world and it's really interesting
it's just like there's just not enough
time to talk about it also there's there
let's take you so there you have if you
for it when you fertilize externally
there are all sorts of problems about
dilution like I'm just gonna talk about
mechanical problems because that's my
that's my my my oyster here so if you
are an animal that throws your gametes
out into the water
they say you're literally an oyster and
you are just throwing your gametes out
into the water or even better a
something like the you know a coral on
the Great Barrier Reef if you just threw
your gametes out there you get me
through tiny and the ocean is really big
so how are those sperm gonna find how
are they gonna find the egg the eggs
that they need to fertilize turns out
one of the things they found that Oh
like one of my colleagues me Nicole
who's at UC Berkeley has studied with
the animals the animals and the great
and some of her students of stage but
the corals in the Great Barrier Reef is
that they have turned the three the
three-dimensional problem of sperm
finding eggs into a two-dimensional
problem so not only do they release all
their eggs and sperm simultaneously
based on environmental cues they have
sort of this coral orgy where they just
spew gametes out into the water those
gametes are
all those sperm and eggs are also
buoyant so everything floats even though
they are died down here and in three
dimensions all over the reef all of
their sperm eggs float up to the top of
the water forming this two-dimensional
slick and by bites by I'm collapsing the
space that the sperm need to swim around
and they have a much better chance of
finding eggs and getting those eggs
getting fertilized so those are the
sorts of problems that external
fertilization winds up winds up you know
having to face so a whole other suite of
really interesting physical problems
awesome let's give these guys a round of
applause this is an awesome job I feel
like I learned a lot and please hang out
if you can because we they have brought
some samples of things out there so we
have a little bit of an activity a bingo
trivia activity centered on some
specimens anyway before we leave also oh
if you're gonna get the bingo cards we
do have prizes for the first three
people to get bingo so you do have to go
to each station and guess what thing it
is yeah to identify the specimen yeah
and so meet any one of our scientists
here and then we can give you the cards
and give you prizes all right